foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
T joining us on the program uh what do
you think about that of all of the good
play like Drew holiday I think is
hampered by his name Shea gilges
Alexander the whole Hall of very good
I I think the fact that Drew spells it
with a J uh takes it I think out of the
the disappointment of Drew okay
um also I just want to confirm it is the
longest gap between All-Star appearances
uh for an NBA player
um but by golly Golden Boy yeah I agree
about Todd I can't I can't be worried
about a Todd no like if I'm a defense as
great as Todd Gurley was be like you
know hey we're building a defense to
stop Todd
I do think though because I'm sure
you've heard this so they yell Peter on
NFL punts when they don't want you to
touch the ball they yell Peter Peter
Peter and part of the belief behind it
according to the Sims family uh from
what they've told me is no NFL players
are named Peter now I would argue that
Peter Warwick was a really Dynamic Peter
but I do think it's interesting that
when I look at my memory of the NFL I
don't remember a Peter so apparently the
reason you yelled Peter Peter Peter is
there's no NFL players named Peter that
is next level
that's next level stuff right there has
nothing to do with your job with the NBA
but it is next level
I appreciate you know I'm like you at
Eastern Kentucky baby I'm a Swiss army
knife I can kind of do anything no I I
was not a Swiss Army knife
I was I was basically well no you could
be a Swiss army knife but you just don't
pull any of the knives out and just keep
it in the container when you're sitting
on the bench I was basically a spoon
that was in the drawer and it's never
pulled out all right you were the
toothpick on the side that could come
out of the little white one all right
when teams Step Up When a star player is
out we saw that with Milwaukee with you
know one game how do you explain Memphis
last night against the Lakers
it is I have talked to a lot of NBA
players about this Candace and I had
this conversation one time where there
were times where she really didn't feel
like she could go and when she sat she
saw a higher performance from her
teammates because she wasn't there at
all compared to when if she tried to
tough it out and so there is that
reaction of oh they're not here at all
this is what we've seen from Memphis
though for two seasons remember last
year I think there were like 20 and 2 in
the regular season when John Morant
wasn't playing uh I think seeing Xavier
Tillman out duel Anthony Davis was
shocking uh and that's the takeaway that
I have for the Lakers completely is this
cannot be a Anthony Davis steps up when
he thinks it's time this needs to be
what Joel embiid is to the Sixers
Anthony Davis is to the Lakers and I
always go back to the top 75 and the
fact that Anthony Davis made that list
and I know it's not fair but Shaq had
this too Shaq was named to the top 50
and he was less than a decade into the
NBA and he had to live up to that and
then win all those championships after
the fact but he did I think Anthony and
he did and that's that's the dilemma
with Anthony Davis is you cannot get you
cannot let up 23 and 13 as Xavier
Tillman and you don't even hit 10 until
the fourth quarter
um but I I want to say that I really
appreciate Dylan Brooks because
Bruce Wayne would never put on the suit
if there wasn't a joker he would never
get ready if there wasn't the Riddler
and the fact that Dylan Brooks is called
we haven't seen this since Lance
Stephenson someone that is getting in
his face and calling him old
we get LeBron with two days thinking
about him being old at I wanted to stay
Stables crypto.com arena
ethereum is going to go through the roof
I just I love the bad guys because who
wants to be the one that nobody likes
Dylan Brooks probably grew up with
LeBron as a hero and he's calling him an
MF and bum like to his face it's not a
fun role but I appreciate him so much
okay he he's obviously baiting LeBron
like he probably would love nothing
better than LeBron to waste all of his
energy in game three try to put you know
40 on him and take him out of the game
you know where he had been relying on
his role players and now you know I
don't know if LeBron takes the bait
because he's been down the road many
many times but I brought this up to Jim
Jackson yesterday and he sent it right
back to me I said I don't remember guys
doing that to Michael Jordan This level
of disrespect he goes oh no we did you
just paid the price but guys did it the
Pistons as a team did it and this is
pre-social Media
but he said you know you would get in
Mike's face or Kobe's face or Bird's
face and I just didn't remember the
level of it feels like disrespect to
LeBron what Memphis does certainly with
Dylan Brooks well we I I've heard so
many stories about you don't want to
wake the black cat in Jordan where
somebody says something early or
somebody says something at halftime and
then everybody looks at the guy or like
are you crazy the Jordan drops 30 on
your head in the second half or uh he
heard something golfing and then goes
out that night and drops 40. uh I just
think you know right now we're living
each game in real time uh and I also
think this is going to be the media nerd
side of me I think we have more cameras
than ever before that have that I think
there's always three dedicated to being
on LeBron and they're in slow motion and
they're zoomed in 50x so maybe we just
missed them back in the days of Bob
Costas on NBC
um but oh yeah like now now we're
zooming in and spits flying and tempers
are flaring I'm talking Adam lefco host
of NBA on TNT on Tuesdays how does Steve
Kerr spin this how do you make this a
positive and build momentum against
Sacramento
I think Steve Kerr goes in there and
says the last six times we faced this
team at home we've beat them by 11 or
more points I think he says we've done
what we've done all year we were 11 and
30 on the road and we've been 33 and 8
at home that's the part of this that I
don't think people are thinking about
the Warriors by the numbers were going
to lose those two games they are the
lower seed in Sacramento and they've
been historically the worst Home Road
split in the history of the NBA and now
they are going to where they are 33 and
8 at home I think I think Steve knows
that is often I believe if I'm going to
make a bold prediction here on The Dan
Patrick Show whoa okay hold on here this
is the hold on here okay yeah if I could
get like a music or a drum roll or
something here we go Adam lefko NBA on
TNT Tuesdays
tonight will be
the Jonathan kaminga game oh okay this
will be the game where we got you doing
the show tomorrow being like this is why
they didn't trade the guy I think he's
gonna have thunderous dunks he's going
to be in that point forward roll kind of
dishing it out tonight is the Jonathan
kaminga game I think I think the fact
that I looked this up today Sacramento
has not started a series up 3-0
since the championship in 1951.
the last time they won Sacramento has
not gone up 3-0 in a series since
1951. golden state has not lost three
games in a playoff series since they
blew the 3-1 lead to the Cavs
I don't think it happens tonight I'm
going Warriors but bigger picture who
wins this series
oh
uh I'm still gonna take the Warriors I
think it goes game seven I think it's in
Sacramento and I know we could talk
about Home Road one team has been in
game sevens for the last 10 years and
one hasn't been the playoffs since 17.
so I'm going to take I'm going to man
the odds probably right now I don't know
what uh sports book you're affiliated
with I'm sure it's pretty nice for the
Warriors to win the series I'm looking
at the early odds to win the NBA Finals
MVP
yes according to DraftKings do you want
to guess early odds MVP
I'm going to say uh the early favorite
is Jason Tatum he's second
I'm gonna say the early favorite Is
Nicoli jokic he is fifth
Giannis yes
okay yeah then Tatum Kevin Durant Joe
Ellen bead and then the Joker
I'm also interested in this that the
suns are favored against the Clippers
tonight
and in La yes but having watched the
clip the sons had to play a perfect game
in game two
you know they were down 12. yeah they're
in the second quarter but they they
don't have any depth and I know the
Clippers don't have Paul George because
if they did then they would win this
series and they still might but why do
you think Phoenix is favored against the
Clippers when they had to play a perfect
game in game two and now the Clippers
are at home
uh I always look at the odds because I'm
a degenerate I'm thinking about they're
trying to induce bets not that they
believe that's what's the spread do you
have that I have uh the sun's by two and
a half that's a lot it is yeah I
um I
so my degenerate brain goes there was a
big bet placed on the Clippers and the
books are needing to induce more bets
um by the way or or there's a lot of
money on the Suns and they're trying to
get more money to come onto the Clippers
right now
um
yeah I I think also there's
um just in the playoffs I'm always
amazed the recency bias from game to
game and how uh you know a team wins and
it's can you believe that the suns are
going to win this series yeah Kawhi has
looked masterful yeah
masterful yeah
but look if the sun's blowing it'll be
the biggest blown opportunity since
Jenny batchy wow
I don't think you can talk about my
former girlfriend like that well you
know
when I talked to Jay cutley every day oh
it's Jake Jacob J kefley yeah almost you
almost pulled it off there if my T's
look like ABS that was that was a Jenny
batchy right there
too soon too soon I still love it still
love her Sorry by the way uh
James Harden's storyline playoff time
because I love what the Sixers did this
year it was quiet most of the
conversation was embed winning the MVP
Hardin played at a really nice level you
know leading the league in assists he
could get you 21 zero drama there's no
Ben Simmons there's no there's nothing
going on here which I like for this team
but in the playoffs James Harden is
going to have to be able to be a little
bit more
and we've seen playoff Harden and it not
a pretty picture
I'm going to the game tonight
and I'm going with your buddies uh Nick
Wright and
um
I uh this is my team like I was raised a
Sixers fan
game one is not sustainable seven threes
most in a playoff game in Sixers history
since Iverson uh and then we but we've
seen in games one and two his inability
to explode in the lane his inability to
compete around the basket is a huge
issue also he's not going to the free
throw line anymore where him and embiid
were number one and number two in free
throw attempts and that's how they would
change the game they'd get everybody in
foul trouble they'd slow the game down I
think what gives me a little bit of Hope
for the Sixers is Tyrese Maxie made the
jump from game one to game two the
question is can hardens facilitating
plus Maxi's explosiveness and embiid
down low can that be sustainable my
problem is right now the Nets are
completely selling out and and B on
doubling embed and embiid is still
catching the ball 20 25 feet from the
basket and trying to play this
facilitator role let's see if it happens
tonight games one and two first half
he'd catch the ball out there the
offense would be stagnant second half
he'd go to the block and then he'd go
from there but from hardin's perspective
it's the reason why I don't think the
Sixers can beat the bucks or the Celtics
is because I think that the Celtics have
a number of guys that can take harden
off the dribble that I don't think
Hardin can take off the dribble pardon's
not faster than white he's not faster
than Tatum he's definitely not faster
than brown I think Marcus Smart locks
him up and then at that point you're a
spot up shooter and I don't think seven
threes is something you can expect every
game
how about a round of applause for Adam
lefko who brought it I think nice I mean
fritzy didn't want him on the show today
but let's go really typical energy
typical time yeah nobody's afraid of
somebody named Todd so lefko Dan I have
a yeah I have a career question for you
since this is like a staple yeah I saw
that I saw you you got like this big
interview on a website like awful
announcing about your philosophy and
doing your hosting stuff and
I thought I thought there might be a
name drop in there that you know what I
drop you every time Dan Patrick said to
be like John Stockton just dish make
everybody better I I didn't I didn't
hear didn't re did they edit it out you
literally read the one article right
yeah yeah I've been you I've been
dropping your name in every interview
I'd like to get the Search terms I'd
like to correction uh you know an update
on that okay so what's the career advice
I can give you okay I have I have a joke
so do you know what chat GPT is yes
okay so I heard you guys talking about
trash talk yeah and so I asked chat GPT
I said you're a world-class comedian and
you were playing basketball with Dan
Patrick what Trash Talk would you say to
him and I just I want to say uh one of
them all right here we go boy their
comedy stinks okay okay hey Dan is your
jump shot sponsored by NASA because it's
taking so long to come back down to
earth I thought it was an orbit
chat GPT
it's too wordy lefko
I've seen better defense in a toddler
soccer game Dan at least they all chase
the ball together you on the other hand
seem to be playing hide and seek with it
once again
too wordy and too much like Dad jokes
if your basketball skills were a sports
news headline it'd read breaking news
Dan Patrick's ankle breaker breaks own
ankles Witnesses stunt
you know
I have to admit you're you're making me
miss Todd giving me mock headlines
so I asked also chat GPT for three jokes
about Dan's producer Todd Fritz
um and I thought this one was really
good Todd's love for sports trivia is
legendary I bet if you asked him how
many dimples there are on a golf ball
he'd not only give you the exact number
but also provide a detailed history of
dimple design and its impact on ball
trajectory and he'd do it while booking
you your next A-list guest boom wow that
hold on is this a rose my insides are
hurting from laughing so much
[Laughter]
okay oh Mike you know what let me check
let me take back the round of applause
for Adam lefko oh wait he deserves way
more that that was hilarious yeah wow
I'm just on here all the time asking
like different okay
shut the hell up
my career question for you is Dan okay
when you went from growing vertically to
like I want to get the next job yeah to
horizontally when you were like I want
to do more yeah what was the big
decision that you make that you're like
man I'm I'm so thankful I did that when
you went horizontally instead of
vertically
well I was doing SportsCenter but then I
would volunteer to do play-by-play on
the weekends where I didn't even get
paid at ESPN I just said could I do some
college basketball games I wanted to get
out I wanted to meet more coaches and
players and kind of be a little bit more
well-rounded get more sources things
like that then there was ESPN radio and
I started volunteering for that on the
weekends as well
and this is when I was still doing the
11 o'clock Sports Center
I just said you know what and they
didn't want me to do either one of those
and I said well I'm going to volunteer
you can't turn me down so I I was not
afraid to try a couple of things
even though I was still doing something
at a pretty high level doing the 11
o'clock Sports Center
um and you just started to see changes
happening yeah yes yes it just makes you
more well-rounded with stories uh you
know having people you can call is so
invaluable in this business when you
have somebody you trust and you've been
in doing this for you know now 40 years
you're able to get that information and
information is key in this in this in
this small little world that we're in I
gotta start talking to more people than
just Todd and Nick Wright
hey when you uh when you see Nick right
tell him I asked about his wife
I will okay I will I don't know if
that's a burn or you're actually being
uh genuine so you'll you'll see Maya's
reaction he really he loves that I love
his wife I appreciate his wife I will I
will say hi for you once again round of
applause for Adam lefko yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah love you guys yeah all of
a sudden Todd seems funny you know
so uh NBA on TNT Tuesdays also hosting
Bleacher Reports NFL draft show for the
10th straight year that'll be next
Thursday we take a break play of the day
up next